when did you start doing stand-up oh I
met you two three weeks in for like the
buff or more like four years are you 38
you started at 38 34 34 oh yeah because
I then I then I met you in DC no this
the cool thing this is okay how do we
mean yeah I mean I saw you at the comic
store said he'll introduce myself and
then you told me you asked me where else
from then you need to I will I'm gonna
put you at the DC I'm gonna put you over
the DC Improv you just maybe you just
you just said that to me yeah weirdly
enough we were both in town and he put
me up on a show Wow so that's how you
took me to the Korean restaurant the
Virginia Virginia yeah yeah yeah it
sucks what the Korean restaurants but I
think you framed it like this is the
best Korean food but you know what it
was late and you know your options start
getting really limited and yeah you're
then you're right in that in that
scenario you're right it's either that
Denny's so you know yeah yeah yeah oh
you're such a nice guy he picked me up
with his wife didn't remember I remember
having your little dog there that little
white dog you still have that guy yeah
what's his name
Dubi Dubi and they drove me to Virginia
late at night and we had Korean food
you're funny though you're like there's
something about you that's that I can
see working in Hollywood I don't say
that a lot about people but I don't
think that you would you could play a
lawyer both Asian characters are those
characters they're not ever like right
but do not golf I know a key agent dudes
not too many but like a guy that like
you know let's say I was in Hawaii
there's a movie about Hawaii and he
needs some you know diamonds to be like
you know to convert them into money
you're the guy to see yeah what does
that role come up you don't audition a
lot not too much not too much people
always try to get me to do stuff but I'm
just sewing to stand up
no I do open mics three open mics at
night you know I do uh run my shop do do
bikes that's it
where people want to go hang out I just
want to go home right and then shot it
just real you're real I just care about
comedy I don't really care about Fame
too much just wanted to be funny how and
why did you get into it I just crazy
story so um and this is so I always
wanted make people laugh and then I'm so
when my grandfather was passing right
they said he had two months to live
and he said oh they say laughter extends
your life so I kept making him laugh
every second I could he end up living
like 14 months because of your comedy I
would hope that is that good I would do
anything yeah literally like played with
like this old black dudes like flick
this black dudes penis that was sleeping
next to him to make so I'm not sure if
it worked I'm not gonna say it did I
don't know yeah just in case it did
maybe I could do that for somebody else
if I really work on your I would even
know if I'd if I did it but if I get
funny enough maybe he died in America he
died in America aged 90 90 who said he
pretty much he was the biggest male
influence in my life so we he was around
he had me young that's why I related
Willie with the black kids you know to
me like he wasn't he was he was ah
because you were abandoned kinda yeah my
uh my my parent member my parent my
birth parents had me really young so my
dad's sister raised me so she's like mom
you know they kind of went off and did
they don't think they partied they were
young you know oh so your Korean parents
mm-hmm that partied yeah it America yeah
they would party do a good he was very
young and irresponsible would you say
there's a distinct difference between
the Korean the Koreans and DC or
Virginia versus the Koreans in LA I
don't really seem too much of that I
didn't know too many back there only the
ones done I knew it the ones in church
you know like my mom forced me to go to
Korean church so here there are a lot of
Koreans in Virginia who's like yeah
there are a lot yeah yeah dude now will
you hung out with then a lot of black
kids and some that did they give you
nicknames I was whoever
most relevant Asian person was
shortchanged here like whatever like
look at mr. mee
[Laughter]
[Music]
we ever doctor can't